I gotta ask was the blue in the pink is
this boy-girl do we know what the gender
of the baby is we don't know yet we
actually just took a blood test because
we want to know really fast so we should
know in the next Lake we purchased what
means you guys want to find out so fast
um let's start playing it yeah I just
get all the things well congratulations
to you guys I mean wedding baby
it's like practically nothing is
happened you know the last time I talked
to you I asked you about kids and you
said he definitely wanted kids so I
gotta ask it was this one time yeah that
is a pleasant surprise it was a great
surprise
great little miracle we actually found
out I was a little late so we we found
out in Mexico actually and we took a
pregnancy test in Mexico re-sodded thing
and we're like what does that even say
so we googled it because the pregnancy
test was in Spanish was bright oh my
gosh that is amazing so so much happened
in paradise yo was that moment caught on
camera no no that was for us alone on
the streets of style eater
[Music]
you